if you've ever been to Malaysia or maybe
Thailand or Costa Rica or Sri Lanka you
know
you know the grip that certain local
monkeys have on the community you've
experienced what it's like to live under
a ruthless regime sometimes called the
monkey Mafia you quickly learn you can
never let your guard down any snacks you
have put a giant Target on your back and
if you don't have any snacks anything
you own is still at risk some monkeys
have learned to steal your camera or
your phone and hold it hostage until you
cough up some snacks they are extremely
clever and sometimes it feels like they
use this cleverness for Pure Evil
they're like small humans with small
thieving hands born with no sense of
right and wrong a truly terrifying
combination although I am mostly joking
these monkeys do present some
interesting behavioral biology and even
philosophical questions if they're so
smart so organized and live in such
tight social groups do they have some
version of morality even for Humanity
defining morality has been a
philosophical conundrum for Millennia
but in general it refers to what
societies determine as right and
acceptable and is what enables people to
live cooperatively in groups
sometimes acting in a moral manner means
individuals must sacrifice their own
short-term interests to benefit others
if monkeys live in groups much like we
do do they require a similar social
contract are monkeys capable of sympathy
and compassion and also their negative
counterparts such as malice and spite do
they have a sense of what is fair and
what is not and by looking at our animal
relatives can we learn more about our
own morality its Origins and how we came
to learn right from wrong
foreign
ists argue that in order to be moral you
must have an understanding of what is
fair
without a concept of fairness we can't
make judgments about other people or
decide who deserves what in any
situation humans are certainly very
sensitive to fairness
Studies have suggested babies as young
as 15 months can work out when food
distribution is unfair and takes steps
to correct this imbalance
and it turns out that at least some
monkeys also have a strong sense of
fairness Brown capuchin monkeys were
tested to see how Cooperative they would
be in a task if they found out they
would not always be fairly compensated
the monkeys were asked to give their
human testers a token and an exchange
they received a treat some monkeys
received a piece of cucumber While
others received a grape the grape being
a much tastier treat to a brown capuchin
monkey the monkeys were able to see each
other and see what their neighbors were
getting for their token Exchange
when the Cucumber monkeys saw that their
neighbors were getting grapes they
became much less willing to engage in
the game
suggesting that they had realized they
were getting a raw deal and didn't want
to cooperate
in some cases the outraged monkeys flung
their exchange tokens away in
frustration interestingly a later
experiment showed that female monkeys
were far more sensitive to unfairness
than male ones
these experiments can tell us how
monkeys react to unaffair situations but
they can't tell us exactly why they
react that way the researchers suggest
it may be that monkeys like humans are
Guided by social emotions thoughts and
feelings based on expectations of how
others will behave and this ability to
anticipate certain behaviors could help
monkeys and humans cooperate and live in
groups
but what about the monkeys getting the
better deal do they feel any kind of
guilt or empathy for their unlucky
friends
empathy is another social skill that has
been argued by philosophers to be
Central to morality without
understanding that others experience
their own wants and needs and without an
ability to imagine what those might be
it would be hard to behave morally
towards others do our monkey Brethren
share our ability to empathize in
another experiment also with capuchin
monkeys test subjects were put into
Pairs and one of each pair was offered a
choice of two tokens a selfish token
gave them access to a slice of apple but
meant their partner got nothing
a helpful token meant that both monkeys
got a treat the monkeys chose the
helpful token more often they didn't see
any reason not to secure their friend a
treat
this changed depending on how well the
monkeys got to know each other when the
monkeys were allowed to interact and
engage with their partner they
consistently chose the helpful token but
when a screen was placed between the
monkeys so that they could see but not
fully engage with their neighbor they
chose selfishly more often
the researchers suggested that the level
of empathy the monkeys felt would depend
on how well they knew their partner
macaques have also been found to express
what could be called empathy a 2015
study placed pairs of macaques opposite
one another and gave them a screen on
which they could press icons that would
offer the other macaque a reward or a
punishment most of the macaques
preferred to give their partner rewards
in the forms of sips of juice then
punishments which were puffs of air to
the eyes when a macaque did choose a
punishment for their neighbor the
scientists observed that they blinked
their own eyes in response to seeing the
other macaque get a big puff of air to
the face
the study authors concluded that these
monkeys can understand and empathize
with what their neighbors are going
through and adapt their own behavior
towards the neighbor accordingly
with a sense of morality comes an
ability to make judgments
humans have developed quite complicated
processes for assessing if someone has
done something bad and on top of this
humans will make a special effort to
punish anyone who violates a social Norm
such as someone who takes resources
unfairly or who does harm to others
and certain monkeys too are more than
happy to punish others
in one study capuchin monkeys were found
to yank on a rope to collapse a table
that is holding another monkey's food if
that other monkey had stolen their food
this seems like a fitting punishment but
these monkeys didn't stop there they
also happily pulled the Rope even if the
other monkey simply got more food than
they did even if it meant neither of
them got any food and an action that
looked a lot like spite and while I'd
like to use this as evidence for a
monkey's lack of moral compass It's
actually an indicator of inequity
aversion an important feature of a
Cooperative Society
and it's one of the most human behaviors
ever observed in monkeys
spite used to be thought to be uniquely
human but the if I can't have it no one
can attitudes evolutionary origins may
be deeper than we thought
but just as monkeys connect spiteful to
each other they also seem to be capable
of forgiveness
monkeys have been seen to make up after
fights and in fact making friends after
a bust up leaves them feeling better
about themselves
when monkeys reconcile after fights they
feel better that is indicators for
distress and anxiety like elevated heart
rate and compulsive scratching decrease
what this doesn't tell us of course is
if monkeys know that they are
reconciling are they driven by a sense
of morality to be fair to be empathetic
and to be apologetic do monkeys act on
instinct or are they actually thinking
about the feelings of their friends and
family
we do have evidence that apes and some
monkeys have a sense of self the mirror
or Mark test is an established test that
tries to prove if an animal is
self-aware that it knows it exists as an
individual an animal has a DOT painted
or a laser pointed on a part of their
body they can't see with their own eyes
and are placed in front of a mirror
animals that don't have a sense of self
it's argued can't understand that the
creature in the mirror is doing exactly
what they do and therefore must be
themselves
they don't try to find the dot on their
own bodies
animals that do recognize that the
mirror creature is performing the same
actions and therefore must represent
themselves we'll try to touch the
painted dot on their own head it's not
as easy as it sounds most animals and
kids under two can't pass the test but
some monkeys can
one study demonstrated this with a laser
pointer the monkey in the mirror always
touched the dot on its head and notably
such monkeys with mirrors constantly use
the mirrors to inspect their own butt we
can safely say the monkey absolutely
knows it's him in that mirror but being
aware that you exist and have autonomous
actions still doesn't guarantee a monkey
understands that other monkeys also have
a sense of self
do monkeys know that other monkeys are
their own selves and therefore should be
considered in moral reasoning
a study done on Japanese macaques
suggested they might have a theory of
mind
the scientists used an established
experiment usually used on human
children called The False belief task
the monkeys were shown a video of person
a placing an object in box a
person a leaves the room and person B
moves the object to box B without person
a seeing the scientists then measure
where the monkeys looked when person a
returns to the room to gauge if they
would expect person a to look in box a
or box B and it turns out the monkeys
looked to the original location
suggesting they understood person a
would not know the object had been moved
that is they understood person a had
their own set of beliefs and view of the
world separate to person B and separate
to themselves however a similar study
done on rhesus macaques was less
successful in showing theory of mind so
it likely differs in different species
some researchers suggest that monkeys
understand that other monkeys see hear
and know different things than them but
they probably don't understand that
other monkeys have different beliefs
about the world
so if monkeys can act fairly
empathetically and have the capacity for
forgiveness yet they don't necessarily
understand that other monkeys have their
own beliefs and ideas about the world
are their actions really moral is it
morality if the monkeys aren't
necessarily making a choice about how
they behave is there any other way to
explain their seemingly moral Behavior
foreign
we know that moral behavior in humans
can be linked to certain parts of the
brain and to certain hormones that
modulate brain activity the study of
morality and the brain has been coined
neuromorality and is in its infancy in
science terms it often involves asking
test subjects to carry out certain
actions or watch videos or respond to a
stimulus while having their brain
activity monitored we can see from these
studies that certain neural networks are
associated with assessing the intentions
of others and that these networks can
interact to make a judgment about where
blame lies for certain actions we've
also seen that serotonin can enhance
negative feelings when we observe others
enduring harm making us more likely to
be empathetic
put simply our brains tell us when we
see something wrong and we don't like
how that feels this could help motivate
our pro-social actions
we can even see differences in how the
brain responds to pain and distress in
others and people who have a limited
sense of morality and those who don't
in people who exhibit Psychopathic
Tendencies when shown a situation in
which a third person is hurt their
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex part of
the brain involved in Social decision
making lit up far less than those
without diagnosed Psychopathic
Tendencies what this suggests is that
the behaviors that we generally
understand to underpin morality fairness
empathy and Justice are pretty ingrained
they are written into our brains and
they are observable in our distant
monkey cousins
so is it after all really morality
in perhaps his most famous book The
Selfish Gene the often controversial
Richard Dawkins suggests that altruism
doing something that benefits another at
your own expense is when you get to the
bottom of it non-altruistic the central
argument of his book is that the gene is
the ultimate unit of heritability that
all human behavior boils down to
ensuring your genes are passed On to the
Next Generation
by protecting close relatives even at
risk to yourself you're really
protecting the same genes that reside in
your own DNA is this the root of
morality is our so-called moral Behavior
just another tool in Evolution's box for
enabling the fittest to survive
but even if morality did indeed evolve
as a simple adaptation to allow animals
like us to live in groups or to pass on
the so-called selfish Gene there's
something about morality that seems to
transcend the normal paradigms of the
animal kingdom there's a little bit of
magic in the way we or our monkey
cousins seem to have goodness in their
hearts but sometimes we all get tested
or pushed to our limits we've all been
given a cucumber when our friend got the
grape that we wanted we all deal with
emotions like envy and though we like to
think of ourselves as more evolved than
monkeys we get food Envy too there's
always something sad about eating a bowl
of cereal while watching MasterChef or
bake off on TV or eating a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich while seeing
incredible food your friends are eating
on social media but luckily we don't
have to be the angry cucumber monkey
because luckily we can sign up for
hellofresh before I signed up I always
felt like I was in a cooking rut with no
ideas of what to make always eating
something dumb and sad for dinner but
hellofresh takes away the complicated
meal planning and delivers fresh quality
produce from the farm to your door in
less than a week so you can enjoy the
delicious flavors of Summer right from
home hellofresh offers veggie
pescetarian and fit and wholesome meals
to make it easy to stick to your goal
and their step-by-step recipes are super
easy to follow and pre-portioned
ingredients help me cut out prep time
and food waste so it's perfect for
weeknight meals so to free up your time
eat more delicious meals and to stop
being the angry cucumber monkey go to
hellofresh.com and use code real
science16 for 16 free meals across seven
boxes and three free gifts as always
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
watch something else right now you can
watch our latest video about the
incredible smelling power of dogs or
watch real engineering's latest video
about one company's attempt to Yeet a
satellite into space